comment ça va si vous me suivez vous
savez que la musique rock c'est quelque
chose d'important pour moi c'est un
élément central de ma vie et au milieu
de tout ça au milieu de mon expérience
musicale d'une expérience de guitaristes
et bien il ya marshall marshall c'est un
mets premier ampli et c'est surtout un
coup de coeur musical une très belle
découverte quelque chose que j'aime
beaucoup de pick juillet et marchal est
présent dès évidemment dans l'univers de
la musique au travers des amplis j'dida
notamment parce qu'ils sont présents
également au niveau du grand public avec
plein de produits hors jeu déjà présenté
plein de produits marshall y en a pleins
marque iconique on connaît très très
bien leur style qui se tombent pas leur
style arras et les produits qui marche
super bien
marshall c'est une image marshall c'est
un son marshall c'est un univers
marshall est présent avec des enfants
qui peuvent venir transporté comme cela
dont je vous ai déjà parlé avec des ans
ça que vous pouvez mettre dans votre
salon mais marchal est également présent
dans vos oreilles avec des écouteurs
aujourd'hui vous paraître ce tout
nouveau produit vous parlez des modes de
mode de marchal sont des écouteurs des
écouteurs super intéressant pourquoi
déjà parce qu'on est chez marshall parce
que dans l'univers marshall et que
marshall moi j'aime bien et que j'ai un
lien affectif avec cette marque
et puis parce que c'est écoutant la cbl
ils sont sans concession il marche bien
et je voulais présenter main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai quand on veut se faire
plaisir comme ça avec des écouteurs on
veut vouloir les écouter dans
différentes configurations que ce soit
dans un avion que ça dans un train que
ce soit chez soi au calme que ce soit
dans la rue que ce soit dans un bus que
ce soit dans le métro que ce soit en
marchant que ce soit en se déplaçant où
que ce soit lors d'une réunion de
famille quand votre tata jacqueline elle
vous embête pas ce qu'elle vous raconte
des histoires que vous connaissez déjà
par coeur vous voulez vous isolez
voulait pouvoir prendre un produit qui
écoule voulait pouvoir prendre ici vos
modes de de marshall
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
alors moi ces modes de marshall je les
ai emmené avec moi je me suis baladé les
écouter j'ai détesté
j'ai pris l'avion avec
[Musique]
moi ce que j'aime bien chez marshall
c'est l'idée de retrouver cette
signature sonore
c'est vraiment des points forts cette
marque j'ai testé plein de marques à
plein marc bodiot que j'aime qui
m'intéressent chacune a sa particularité
sa ou ses particularités mais la
particularité forte
on va retrouver chez marshall ici c'est
le son de légende c'est un souk et sur
un pull ise pour venir écouter de la
musique rock mais pas que vous pouvez
venir écouter automne de la musique
classique du hip hop
après je vais vous montrer parce qu'une
application qui vous permet d'aller plus
loin que ça je vous le monde dans
quelques instants mais c'est ça que
j'aime avec cette marque c'est que
lorsque je vais écouter un bon vieux
morceaux de rock avec des guitares très
agressif et déjà trouvé ce sont ici dans
les oreilles ça ça me plaît ça c'est la
base et c'est ce convient d'attendre
d'un produit comme celui-là signé
marshall avec ce logo marshall qui est
quand même le logo iconique
alors ici il n'y a pas de réduction de
bruit active on reste dans une gamme de
prix qui complètement normal énorme et
on est sur une réduction de bruit pas si
une réduction brute passif ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que ça vient vous
boucher les oreilles tout simplement
alors pour vous les bouchers de façon
optimale et bien vous avez plusieurs
tailles d'embouts vous avez du small le
médium le médium qui insérait par défaut
sur vos mails donc ici c'est du médium
vous avez du large et vous avez de
l'extra large donc quelle que soit la
taille de vos oreilles et bien vous avez
des embouts en silicone qui vont être
adaptée à la forme et la taille de vos
oreilles en plus de ça ici sont tactiles
vous avez un petit pavé de commandes
très simple à venir prendre en main très
intuitif donc ça ça marche bien vous
appuyez d'une fois à lecture vous
rappeler une fois poste quelqu'un vous
appelle depuis une fois vous décrochez
vous rappeler une fois vous raccrocher
et si quelqu'un vous appelle il voulait
pas répondre nous appuyer deux fois vous
en débarrasser alors si vous écoutez de
la musique vous êtes payé deux fois dans
son suivant trois fois morceau précédent
et à gauche vous activez le mode
transparence ou alors vous réveillez
vous supprimez le vote transparent si
vous restez sur une réduction de bruit
passive et si vous appuyez deux fois ici
à gauche vous avez venir active et
l'assistant vocal de vote soit retraite
et puis de la même manière avec votre
écouteurs gauche pouvait venir répondre
à un appel raccrocher ou alors rejeté
l'appel d'un pur de fans vous voyez
qu'en fait les commandes tactiles à son
hyper simple hyper intuitive
le truc qui pourrait manquer un petit
peu ici c'est le fait de se dire on ne
peut pas venir régler sont voulus si
vous voulez régler votre volume il faut
faire à partir de votre appareil se sont
un smartphone ou un autre au quai très
très bien pas de souci là-dessus pour
moi la qualité sonore est là encore
faut-il aimer leçon marshall
personnellement c'est mon cas fait
intéressant c'est la première fois qu'on
voit arriver marshall avec des écouteurs
bluetooth intra auriculaire à
l'intérieur vous avez un transducteur de
6 mm chaque côté l'état lire à droite et
à gauche qui vous donne une gamme de
fréquences de 20
à 20 kg alors ça c'est un grand
classique dans l'audio niveau des
écouteurs lors le prix je donne tout de
suite 179 euros 1 7 979 euros pour venir
profiter d'une expérience marchak
directement ici dans vos oreilles
c'est très personnel la façon dont on va
vouloir venir écouter la façon dont on
va venir aimé le sont parce que je peux
bien vous dire ici c'est que moi c'est
une expérience que j'ai vraiment bien
aimé dans différentes conditions j'ai
aimé effectivement ce sont cette
typologie de son qu'on va retrouver ici
chez marchasson qui est assez typé quand
même mais qui fonctionne vraiment bien
et qui en tout cas chez moi fait est qu
ils ont un vrai savoir faire au niveau
de l'audio et ils viennent le mettre au
service de vos oreilles donc là ça me
plaît bien
autre point qui est plutôt pas mal ici
et c'est l'autonomie on va jusqu'à 25
heures d'autonomie alors pas 25 heures
ici avec la qui coûtera dès que chaque
écouteur on arrive à 5h à peu près mais
vous avez jusqu'à 5 recharge grâce à
votre boîtier ce qui vous permettra de
le monter jusqu'à 25 heures et si vous
voulez une recharge complète il vous
faudra deux heures point qu'il est
intéressant votre boîtier est certifié
ipx4 c'est ce qu'on trouve usuellement
haut niveau même des écouteurs non ici
les écouteurs sont pas certifiés ipx4 et
sont certifiés ipx5 alors qu'est ce que
ça veut dire tout ça ça veut pas dire
pour autant vous allez pouvoir vous
baigner avec et qu'ils sont étanches et
qu'on peut aller se baigner dans la
piscine avec non ça veut dire que si
vous transpirez vous allez faire du
sport avec ses routes de l'eau ça
devrait aller et il y aura absolument
aucun problème là dessus que ce soir sur
votre boîtier alors on va moins venir
transpirer soit votée et venir s'essuyer
comme ça oui ça s'est pas trop fait pour
ça mais si vous avez l'eau dessus qui
sont posées et qu'il pleut ou vous
renverser un verre dessus et bien pas de
souci là dessus vous êtes dans un
festival quand les festivals vont
revenir et bien vous pourrez venir
renversé de l'eau dessus et la même
chose ici notamment au niveau de la
transpiration et du sport donc ça ça
donne et à notre mode qui est
intéressant là dessus c'est ce qu'on
appellera le mot de transparence alors
je vous explique très très rapidement
lorsque vous avez une réduction de bruit
possible comme ça eh bien ça fait quoi
ça vient de boucher les oreilles ce qui
fait qu'en fait on s'entend soit par les
dents dans sa tête on entend beaucoup
moins les gens en face parce que ça file
trop leçons mais vous pouvez venir
activer le mode transparence il va dire
capter le son au travers des micros et
l'avenir vous l'injecter vous
directement dans vos haut-parleurs pour
vous puissiez converser de façon normale
avec quelqu'un ou même sens venir parler
pour vous puissiez être attentif à ce
qui se passe autour de vous notamment
lors de vos déplacements aux bills si
vous devez traverser vous entendez ce
qui se passe est ici il faut savoir que
vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 et peut même
vous amuser à les faire sauter comme ça
ce qui est super intéressant également
si vous avez une application une
application qui vous donne quelques
informations notamment votre niveau
batterie avec vos écouteurs droite et
gauche et vous voyez que vous avez même
si un équaliseur alors à s'impliquer
super intéressant qui moi me plaît
beaucoup
effectivement je fais marshall et julien
vallée chez beaucoup de constructeurs
qui n'ont pas d'écho à l'isr il pouvait
venir régler des bandes de fréquences à
vous en avez cinq vous avez les
essentielles vous avez le sens 60 hertz
qui va être vraiment le son je dirais le
plus grave le 400 hertz on est sur du
bas médium un kilo on est sur du médium
deux kilos et demi ils sont du médium
aigu et 6 kg 25 on est sur du médium
aigu plus plus on peut pas monter au
delà on n'a pas le 12 kg n'a pas de 16
kilos ont déjà ici il ya de quoi faire
ça c'est réglages que je me suis fais
moi vous avez trois possibilités le tout
premier bien c'est ce qu'ils appelleront
le leçon marshall original c'est flat
c'est hyper droit là dessus il ya rien à
faire vous en avez un deuxième que vous
me réglez vous quand vous souhaiter que
nos troisièmes pour venir également
régler comme vous voulez alors vous avez
plusieurs possibilités soit personnalisé
marshall soit rock soit spoken enfin il
y en a pas mal voilà vous avez le choix
entre quelques modes différents moi ce
que je vous conseille vraiment venir
faire c'est d'aller sur le mode
personnalisé
jeudi le régler en fonction de ce que
vous aimez en fonction de vos goûts en
fonction de votre oreille on n'a pas
tous la même oreille pour passer le
premier mode et le deuxième mode et bien
ces deux modes transparence là ici par
exemple eh bien on peut choisir le
niveau de mode transparent c'est à dire
le son qui va être injecté dans nos
écouteurs soit 100 % soit un tout petit
peu ce pas beaucoup en fonction du bruit
environnant et vous pouvez venir
l'éteindre également ici donc ça c'est à
vous de voir en fonction de ce dont vous
allez avoir besoin le free cash flow a
regretté également un petit peu ici
c'est que dans l'application on ne
puisse pas venir à signer les boutons
différemment par exemple si moi j'ai
envie en appuyant deux fois que ça vient
de monter le volume neiges que passe un
truc qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui chez
marshall mais qui peut être allez savoir
pour être amélioré dans une dans une
version suivante en tout cas tels qu'ils
sont là il fonctionne bien ils plaisent
bien 170 euros
c'est vrai que c'est un petit budget
mais pour avoir un produit comme ça avec
ce design avec regarder on retrouve le
petit bouton marshall ici on retrouve
vraiment tous les codes de marshall haut
niveau au niveau de l'étui tout ce que
j'avais sur mon ampli quand j'étais plus
jeune donc ça me plaît toujours
et c'est une vraie continuité dans la
gamme marshall parce que quel que soit
le produit que vous allez prendre
eh bien vous avez toujours avoir ce côté
là ce que tu es noir c'est noir sur
blanc y en a pas d'autres ici ce côté
doré avec les boutons en plus de suivre
et à l'intérieur c'est hyper classe
c'est un produit alors s'il vous
intéresse mais le lien en bas dans la
description je vous en parle parce que
j'aime bien marshall j'aime bien leurs
produits ce qui fonctionne bien
le son est vraiment très très cool une
fois de plus venez dans vos paramètres
réglez les quoi l'isr en fonction de vos
goûts à vous en fonction de ce que vous
voulez en faire vous ne pouvez pas tout
faire vous n'avez pas de réduction brute
l'activisme et ce n'est pas le propos la
réduction brute passive marche bien le
fait d'avoir le mot transparence ça
fonctionne enfin quoi vous expliquer
c'est un produit qui me plaît qui me
séduit et s'il vous intéresse
le lien est en bas a vous de me dire
vous maintenant ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire nous on se retrouve
très vite pour parler de textes bien
évidemment et puis au paradou 12,6 un
peu plus tard des bisous l'amour prenez
soin de vous ciao